[Music]
the attacking infantry advances steadily
their elephants already having broken
the defensive line the King tries to
retreat but enemy cavalry flanks him
from the rear escaping is impossible but
this isn't a real war nor is it just a
game over the roughly one and a half
millennia of its existence chess has
been known as a tool of military
strategy a metaphor for human affairs
and a benchmark of genius
while our earliest records of chess are
in the seventh century legend tells of
the game's origins lie a century earlier
supposedly when the youngest Prince of
the Gupta Empire was killed in battle
his brother devised a way of
representing the scene to their grieving
mother set on that 8x8 octopod aboard
used for other popular pastimes a new
game emerged with two key features
different rules for moving different
types of pieces and a single King piece
whose fate determined the outcome the
game was originally known as chaturanga
a Sanskrit word for four divisions but
with its spread to Sassanid Persia it
acquired its current name and
terminology chess derived from cha
meaning King and checkmate from Shabbat
or the king is helpless after the
seventh century Islamic conquest of
Persia chess was introduced to the Arab
world transcending its role as a
tactical simulation it eventually became
a rich source of poetic imagery
diplomats and courtiers use chess terms
to describe political power ruling
caliphs became avid players themselves
and historian al masud II considered the
game a testament to human free will
compared to games of chance
medieval trade along the Silk Road
carried the game to East and Southeast
Asia where many local variants
developed in China chess pieces were
placed at intersections of board squares
rather than inside them as in the native
strategy game go the reign of mongol
leader
tamerlane saw an 11 by 10 board with
safe squares called Citadel's and in
Japanese shogi captured pieces could be
used by the opposing player but it was
in Europe that chess began to take on
its modern form by a thousand AD the
game had become part of courtly
education chess was used as an allegory
for different social classes performing
their proper roles and the pieces were
reinterpreted in their new context at
the same time the church remains
suspicious of games moralists cautioned
against devoting too much time to them
with chess even being briefly banned in
France yet the game proliferated and the
15th century saw it Co hearing into the
form we know today the relatively weak
piece of advisor was recast as a more
powerful queen perhaps inspired by the
recent surge of strong female leaders
this change accelerated the game's pace
and as other rules were popularized
treatises analyzing common openings and
ten games
appeared chess theory was born with the
enlightenment-era the game moved from
royal courts to coffee houses chess was
now seen as an expression of creativity
encouraging bold moves and dramatic
plays this romantic style reached its
peak in the immortal game of 1851 where
Adolphe Anderson managed a checkmate
after sacrificing his Queen and both
rooks but the emergence of formal
competitive play in the late 19th
century meant that strategic calculation
would eventually Trump with dramatic
flair and with the rise of international
competition chess took on a new
geopolitical importance during the Cold
War the Soviet Union devoted great
resources to
cultivating chess talent dominating the
championships for the rest of the
century for the player who would truly
upset Russian dominance was not a
citizen of another country but an IBM
computer called deep blue chess-playing
computers have been developed for
decades but deep blues triumph of a Gary
Kasparov in 1997 was the first time a
machine had defeated a sitting champion
today chess software is capable of
consistently defeating the best human
players but just like the game they've
mastered these machines are products of
human ingenuity and perhaps that same
ingenuity will guide us out of this
apparent checkmate did you know that the
treadmill was originally designed to be
a torture device learn more about its
dark and twisted past with this video
[Music]